hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to resident evil 3
we've got an override key which I think
goes to this door right yes definitely
yes thanks thank you oh no thank you no
thank you no thank you bad not where I
wanted to be no not where I wanted to be
I don't like it see you under there I
see oh yeah get out of here loser
alright I don't know if I was in you why
everything about this place is awful I
don't know if there was something down
there that I oh there is how am I gonna
go alright you know it's good I'm going
for it kick you downstairs oh oh
get rekt alright you guys need to stop
being [ __ ] alright
oh [ __ ] thanks for the Dodge okay okay
there's herb here it better not just be
a goddamn herb I swear Oh shotgun shells
too explosive eh oh thank you okay
apparently I can go here good one
gunpowder good or any gunpowder period
are you zom-bone ii do you have a note
oh yeah okay I love reading material
good happen our worst case scenario the
t-virus is somehow leaked under orders
from dr. bard I'm to manufacture mass
quantities of the vaccine I prepared a
culture of the tea fires antigen now I
just need to combine it with the
adjuvant to enhance its effects I should
be able to Bruce enough vaccine to save
all the surviving citizens the adjuvant
samples are stored in the incubation lab
the test subjects are already wandering
the halls I'd better find a way to get
some samples while this culture is
maturing if I don't make it back please
complete the synthesis process try to
find a way to stop this outbreak the
least we can do after setting these
horrifying events in motion yeah yeah a
little bit yeah it's kind of your fault
kind of all your fault hit
baby oh yes please good thing I have
that in my inventory and it can stack
and I feel good for having that around
I'm guessing those can and probably
might actually melt those subjects
that's gotta be why they exist right
otherwise what would be even the point
another case over there how do I get to
you are you open oh this must be what
power why hey wait a minute that's not
not very useful I will leave you there
for now good stuff thank you for that
they did it I'm a hero and now I know
that there's medical spray there if and
when I ever go crazy enough and decide
that I want it as if I Jill Valentine
take any damage not I said the gym I
don't know why my own Oh No oh he happy
oh he's happy he's got a little smile oh
all of these are like the the ex Weapon
series aren't they let the frog monster
yeah this seems to be where they're made
oh yeah oh you got a mr. X face you're
not looking too good otherwise but you
definitely got the face these are
diamonds pirates that's the name for
them yucky yucky Oh interesting
oh you're missing a little hit there but
that's okay nice waist nice neck nice I
feel like just like whoever did the
character Mazda this is like oh here
stretch stretch do that there oh yeah
you're not looking so good skip leg day
oh he's so happy oh he's so happy look
I'm happy
Oh
you're happy okay well some of them
ain't looking so good all those guys
though look perfect perfect enough just
to jump out and probably kill me oh is
that a baby tyrunt okay was there
anything oh my god that was easy to miss
holy [ __ ]
oh sure a lot of crap in my inventory I
sure wish I could actually store it
that'd be great guess I'm going up I
could really use with a space clearing
box now there's another box over here
how am I gonna get you in my inventory
I'm gonna have to combine something
I hate combining things nope you
definitely don't get to live oh god
you're not even technically alive maybe
you're like some weird tyrants baby oh I
can't carry that oh yeah I should do
this shouldn't that get you damn you
guys please tell me that other guys down
for at least a second to read senior
fellow dr. Frankel please allow me to
send my heartfelt congratulations to you
and your colleagues at umbrella Europe
for completing nemesis a truly
remarkable achievement in the field of
bio weapons research introducing a
parasitic organism into a tyrants brain
to gain external control of it how can I
not marvel it's such a wild idea however
from a medical perspective I must
emphatically state my disapproval for
this shift away from the established
umbrella policy by turning to the use of
parasites you are setting a dangerous
precedent viruses can be kept in check I
believed in an effective vaccine can be
developed for any virus on earth with
abundant funding and about Eve samples
of course can you say the same for
parasites however doctors have tried in
vain to develop a vaccine for malaria
parasites like Plasmodium are far more
genetically complex than the T virus and
a thing that will submit to control is
utter folly this letter stopped being
praised perhaps in your country
consumers are willing to buy automobiles
with no brakes but here in America they
know better then again I recall you have
a degree in economics so no doubt you've
already devised a brilliant marketing
strategy to win over the naysayers I'll
look forward to your talk at the Forum
in Berlin next month in the meantime I
shall be exploring medical solutions to
the hubristic problem you've wasted upon
us
Nathaniel Bart um that was not a letter
of praise I'm detecting sarcasm damn you
for making me experience sarcasm oh [ __ ]
nope god damn it no way to god there's
no way it can't be done there's no
dodging ever sorry I went a little
overboard with that okay so I can use
one of these and then grab that and then
I can get out okay and then there was
there was another one on the outside
god is it's not the only thing in here
what else is in here
oh god that yes of course I need the
actual example of course I would need it
[ __ ] when adjutant antigens to increase
immune systems this is who completely
woven blah blah I wish I could just
combine this fool yes I can yes I can
that's so perfect my eyes can't track
his movements I'm sure I'll be fine
down here definitely one of those jars
isn't gonna bust open and attack me
that's definitely not going to happen
Daffy and
[Music]
that thing that I didn't want to happen
oh my god oh god I'm stuck that's fire
ever it burns weird I'm the only
instruction I'll be fine
alright you you can stay for that you
got a face full of oh no guys wait I
didn't realize the door was closed tight
guys please don't put my save so far
back please please
[Music]
here comes the earth-shattering kaboom
yep another one straight up after it
Oh God what the Frick
not in the corner not in the corner get
me out of the quarter god damn it thank
you
there you go any more any more coming
out any more coming out yeah that's what
I thought that's a--that's a big scratch
on my back this abandoning some first
aid spray yeesh
Oh first aid spray Oh what do you know
there's some in this box right over here
good thing they're not gonna find ribs
only they knew that was my one weakness
all right now that these jerkwads know
that I'm not one to be trifled with
they'll obviously stay out of my way
[Music]
okay thank you I'm immune you can't
touch me
well so what was up here didn't I didn't
I want to go up here stop beating you go
away wasn't there something up here did
I not go up here I feel like I didn't go
up here ah interesting interesting
interesting what's in here what's in
here what's in here once again where am
I going what am i doing what am i doing
where am i what is in here handgun that
it in here cool good good ah dear dr.
Emerson I would like to formally request
the weaponry normally reserved for the
by witnesses esteemed be made available
for any employees interfacing with the
admission and dismissal of test subjects
these test subjects do not present the
same levels of danger as a bio weapon
products but I believe that this
weaponry authorization is advisable as
outlined below recently some of the
tests have developed a new mutation
granting them very high regrowth
abilities our team refers to these
specimens as pale heads they have been
appearing with regularity but the
specific cause is not yet been
determined the astonishing rate at which
these pale heads regenerate makes it
difficult to deliver a lethal blow with
standard weaponry if any sort of system
failure were to occur within our
facility we would be woefully unprepared
to defend ourselves for this reason I
would like to request that a
high-powered weaponry capable of subdue
the pale heads be issued to all of our
employees working and shipping and
processing this will ensure that in the
event of an emergency we'll be able to
quickly eliminate the threat and
evacuate safely thank you very much for
your consideration
Gabrielle Reef well where is that I want
one of those
I get one of those that's our feed
[Music]
that's not what I need at all I can't
hold that what do you expect me to make
handgun ammo like a doof fine yep you
know I don't know why I need to do that
I could've just gone out the door hey go
away go away go away fall down fall down
fall down fall down fall down fall down
oh never written you huh well that was
fun
let me just choke down an herb and I
think that'll be enough take care of
this illness scarf I'm fine you all
better baby I will put this away I
handled that with expertise in a calm
head which is what's necessary in these
emergency crisis situations you gotta
approach it levelly calmly without any
crisis in your blood I got none of that
I know exactly what I am doing anybody
gonna object to me actually making this
damn thing that floated in there I'm
sorry what I got this wrong or I'm
missing a step
[Music]
unauthorized materials detected okay oh
there we go
I needed to combine them I don't know
how I did that by hand but okay there
you go baby ooh interesting interesting
interesting got it baby gah that's how
you do fascinating Wow
that's of enough for the whole world
perfect this will never get broken in my
rap Scalia seven oh I don't like that
careful there oh not down here again
wherever I am where am I
what shot yeah this this vexy is
definitely not gonna get hit
oh where the hell am i hey thanks for
this uh okay I guess I just go drawl
hello
[Music]
damn bow oh not again with the next
thing you weirdo
it's manner where to go where did it go
[Music]
oh you won't be me I punch the grid off
of this you will never be able to beat
me better than you
do you think you can get me you cannot
how do I need to hold it oh I need to
hold it oh I thought I needed to tap it
oh I was about to die
don't mind me wimpy baby over here can't
even fight me try pulling my leg off
yeah I'll probably work out better for
you whoa fire aah okay thank you Andy
well he's definitely dead forever
definitely dead forever hi great first
date hi great good stuff good stuff good
stuff this is a lot of good stuff why
are you giving me good stuff I'm very
worried about it do I want to make mag
ammo now probably giving news because it
wants me to make Magnum ammo but I've
got these a skirt I'll do shot no no not
what I wanted boy that's a lot of
grenades that's a lot of grenades rounds
what are you getting so many grenade
rounds this is about to be a boss fight
is this about to throw down throw down
ho down disposal Center this facility is
to be used for the dissolution and
disposal of test subjects used in nest 2
experiments the potent solvents used
will ensure that any biological matter
within the vat living or dead is
completely dissolved and ready for
disposal please follow all safety
protocols when using the disposal Center
always confirm that no employees are in
the chamber before beginning the
dissolution process always use the
regulated amount of solvent regardless
of the volume or mass being disposed of
if a test subject reacts violently do
not halt the disposal process leave the
chamber filled for at least 12 hours and
check for complete dissolution before
draining right this is how I'm gonna
kill nemesis this is definitely a kill
nemesis situation I can tell because I'm
smart about these things so here's what
I'm gonna do I am guessing this is final
boss time get ready because it's about
to go down so I'm gonna do something
wacky and crazy I'm not gonna go nuts
this is what I'm gonna do we're gonna go
ham with mines on this guy I'm just
gonna go nuts I'm gonna go I'm gonna go
a little crazy I'm gonna go I'm not even
gonna use the Magnum go I'm going
straight up non-stop explosive Oh time
to see what the hell happens
you never know oh this place in God
named him is this what what God give
give what God named in this place oh
this is so final battle and I am so
grenading the ever-loving crap out of
you my dude let me just check to see how
to switch you just pretty okay that's
good
I'll start with flames because I got a
lot of those I'll burn them down oh oh
yeah oh yeah so you know they were
talking about pair of outlets
ribs yeah let the vaccine nicolai don't
the city needs that vaccine more than I
do
I don't think wisdom I'm trying to
impart on you is getting 10 I know but
I'm in this business to get paid so
let's make a deal you go down there
there to the nemesis and I will record
it all and silver come back that put on
a good show
ok fascinating combat data huh alright
hope you hope you have studied up on
grenade launcher cuz that's what we're
gonna get baby that's what we're gonna
get so they said something about
parasites and I'm willing to bet
yes well good thing I got extra no I
done I definitely done well
good thing I'm so strong all right good
thing I've got plenty of this too I wish
I would dodge let's put these suede
there's something going on wait I'm
seeing some I'm seeing something damn
I'm detecting something I didn't get my
pistol I think I need to shoot these
things God the one thing I need to shoot
yep that's definitely the thing god damn
it I didn't get a pistol I only have
grenade launchers what you didn't do the
thing I only have grenade launcher I
have two oh my god I've got the one
thing that I owe it will do second
you missed me [ __ ]
wait no they come back online why why
would they do that
why would they do that
why would they come back online oh yes
please show is that you Carlos you're
okay
let me spot for you
[Music]
let what I don't know what I need
okay I'm just gonna shoot him
hey bud
yeah I see that oh hey bud hey are you
doing hey bud
he's trying to be on a tank a tank eight
you say
yeah I'll do that
I'm doing it
take an acid round nope not gonna risk
oh my gosh did I definitely dodge that
oh all their colorful it's the party run
really I need a different front for this
pump give this to blow again I could
have guessed that oh he needs to be
blown up now I've got now is the time to
blow up
I go gasps no no not now not now I'm
stuck what am I stuck on hey nice thank
you thank you that
if you kill them oh my god he killed it
okay so all I got to do is run away from
those guys that'll be fine all right
okay yep I see that yeah but it changed
over to acid rounds and then I'm gonna
ask them
that doing anything cut up
stop it I said stop okay well alright so
was that just the GAMEOVER combo that I
wasn't able to do anything
was I not able to do it nope I'm back
here now glad I experienced the full
beauty of the GAMEOVER combo maybe I
should just let him burn his the thing
maybe maybe letting a furnace good move
probably chill is that you oh that was
easy yeah let it burn okay there okay
let me spot for you which one you're
gonna hide their behind like a big bitty
baby I see your belly point back them
Browns
and son
Oh
Wow I was gonna go boy yeah as well you
know it's true handgun ammo
thought I got him goddamnit what
okay friendly that work
miss me I'm so dodging I'm so done that
was a Dodge what is this garbage
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
way up no no no no no nothing
what are you doing okay all's good
[Music]
no not not oh my god whoa brick
me the preload is
boring
oh god that's not good that's the
GAMEOVER combo
okay
fun times anymore items here yeah here
we go where's your where's your
really there you go is death
here comes the crane to use it to climb
up
[Music]
oh yeah perfect
thank you I left some supplies down
there maybe I could go back and get them
that's all right Milka me push I'm a
Bellamy's wood
[Music]
move you are indeed melting him into
mush
[Music]
Oh God yep you're melt amend him into
mush
but also I'm what I was gonna say about
the person before is Resident Evil 7 had
like a parasite infection maybe like
this is the origination of the parasite
being a part of the whole Resident Evil
umbrella corporation protocol you know
what I mean I got one magnum bullet for
Nikolai I have to get that vaccine back
yeah and I'm uh I'm gonna get it trust
you me when I say am I gonna get it
alright let's put this way we don't have
any bullets for it anyway so it's just a
waste of space let's bring out the
handgun I actually didn't like the first
model for some reason it just felt weird
when I was shooting it so I'm gonna go
back to the other one so I got Pierce
Steele ooh there's some good howdy
perfect okay first aid spray over there
that's good a book weapon spec sheet
redacted ferromagnetic infantry use
next-generation railgun Oh codename
finger I'm gonna finger me it's a bee's
nest too late researcher Cornell Garner
sixty millimeter ammo six thousand
meters per second suppression of new bio
if it's a case of outbreak extreme
firepower provides the secondary benefit
of completely obliterating the target
leaving no trace behind this thing is
totally rad tyrants out of line just
give them the finger and problem solved
packs the firepower we need it would
even be better if there was a way to
control the output mobility may prove to
be problematic in the field perhaps its
platform could be refined it requires
multiple power sources may be difficult
to secure in practice could you
consolidate to a single power source
where is it
I want it give it to me give it to me
give it to me give me the finger
I want the finger I want it bad give me
the goddamn finger alright what's in
here whoa oh is that the finger is that
the finger that that's got to be the
thing
oh my god let it tell me that I'm gonna
shoot something with the finger hi it's
done give me the vaccine you grease I
[Music]
like we should make our ongoing
arrangement now drop the gun
[Music]
oh no oh no abuse have you ever seen
anything so incredible the back on this
would be worth nearly data but you know
how it is city's about to explode and
you can put a price on life ha ha ha
good luck
does that guy keep getting away go after
Nikolai he's got the vaccine what about
you
we're running out of time I've got this
I've got this hi
I would not say I know you do in two
seconds just so you know this is the
last [ __ ] time if you hadn't known
that I would have got more supplies you
keep catching me at the rock okay here
we go
this opening compartment okay you got
wait hang on now we're old what oh oh oh
I am so strong I love yo screw guns
[Music]
yes yes yes yes it needs power yes yes
yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes yes yes yes Wow yes yes go away I
don't care what you do yes yes I yes
yeah I know I
okay I see
yes okay
you grabbed me no that's how we do oh
but madam alright okay cool cool good
hey let me grab what I need which is
yeah not much I guess just got these
mine rounds so I guess I'll use them got
it alright let's do this
I'll save one more time now that I know
what I'm doing I love that see this is
why I was so out of it when I was
playing doom I was like let me fire the
BFG let me click the button it doesn't
matter if it's all the rest of its
cinematic the fact that I click the
button is what made the difference
that's what made the difference oh yeah
here we go she's just shocked the news
power yeah yeah okay cool
[Music]
Wow
hurry up
Wow I didn't know you could reach me
from there
oh man you bro sticks
did that do it oh yeah that seemed to do
something anyway he uh chocolate
chocolate chocolate chocolate chocolate
chocolate chocolate keep sleeping sorry
I popped your zits I know that really
sucks sometimes everyone hates it I
especially what melted through the over
that was the real good
do I have to
[Music]
yep I definitely do okay let's let's not
try that again
Oh
didn't know the bulldozer was incoming
don't get Oh God
please it's right there let me get it oh
my god let me get it it's right there
oh my god it's break there are you
kidding me just get it it's right there
oh my god that's absurd
that's absurd that's absurd that's it
sir oh come on now come now come now
come now
come now come now come now I'm gonna
[ __ ] you up I'm gonna finger you so good
I'm gonna finger you so hard you are
getting straight-up thing he do
[Music]
I'd say one more oh yes oh yes baby yes
shove it in there yes
good riddance that's what I'm trying to
do that's what I'm doing
oh my god that is what I'm talking about
whoa there's so many supplies here oh I
did not know that that would have been
good enough
oh well who needed it not me good good
good probably should be used my pretty
one oh well oh wait can I go through the
big hole in the center I thought that
was gonna be the thing like I go through
that that's my exit path I carved it out
myself with my own railgun with my own
two railgun hands
yeah okay all right let's do this it
seems fine out
[Music]
oh this looks familiar
maybe let's see about that we shall see
hang on I gotta go check around the back
you never know and there's gonna be
something up apparently there's nothing
man umbrella sure does love their
central shafts their fingers their
shafts they love them all yeah yeah sure
yeah okay hmm no info no info no info
[Music]
promised to this
now do you have any idea what you've
just done no no don't care my client
ordered me to just taking a nap you have
to just do the wait wait what just know
just what what what no I shot him in the
head no what hey my daughter couldn't
leave you in a Carlos's world what was
he doing another grant wait no I what
why didn't he just puce him away why'd
you do it
there is a price tag for everything even
letting a world home who are you working
for
I'll tell you if you get me out of the
ocean I'll pay whatever you want
like I never find out
out of mind little detective work
[Music]
Joe you alright
yeah
[Music]
it's finally over
so long Marcee
[Music]
I felt empty and cold as the heat from
the blast washed others
baby's death wasn't caused by a monster
making fire
human
I decided then inthere the ashes of
Raccoon City would be umbrellas ashes to
I would end them once and for all
hmm then technically Nikolai's goal and
yours were the same okay that final
fight sequence was very contrived and
very like very not elegantly done
however I'm not gonna let that
overshadow the rest of the game which
was also a little contrived a lot of
times but still very fun like it was a
very fun game I liked it the final boss
battle is very nice but I always hate it
when the final boss battle and then the
main antagonist which the nemesis was
not the main antagonist definitely on
the poster yes visually absolutely the
one you fight for the most but it was
very clear from the get-go that Nikolaj
was gonna be the guy and when it comes
down to the stories it always between
the human relationships and that one at
the end there it was just very contrived
why was Carlos taking a nap and then why
was Carlos suddenly able to get back up
and then it's not Jill that is the one
that defeats the villain it's Carlos
that enables Jill to take a shot that
doesn't necessarily kill him and then
leaves the nuke to do the job which only
opens the door to him being like maybe
he's not dead
somehow he survived a nuke I don't know
how that would happen but probably is
the way that's contrived to be and
probably what they wanted to do but at
the same time it's like it robbed Jill
of proving him wrong miss of it because
from the get-go they're their thing was
you didn't know he was dead yet from the
guy that Nikolaj shot first was like yay
and he was like your morals are wrong
you need to be tougher on the inside and
her philosophy is like I will do
whatever it takes to save people that's
always what it's gonna be and in the end
like she didn't get to have her
character reach that final conclusion in
and and in leaving him to die after
shooting him in the shoulder it's not
allowing her to take the moral high
ground it's kind of robbing her of her
last step of growth as a character that
being said I'm fine with like the
vaccine not getting there at the end
that's tragic and it's it's cool like
the fate of Raccoon City was inevitable
I think that was good I like to have
that but it also is justly one of the
story beats that could have been
stronger towards the end however that's
all I'll say about that let's skip this
to get to the end and see what we got
here
all right interesting I did it rank cs6
well two of those were [ __ ] I can
call that the others I earned total
playtime six hours or something that's
not a bit short very short now what I'm
willing to bet what I'm willing to bet
what I'm willing to bet the shop has
been unlocked once used to unlock items
can be earned in green physical feats
such as perfect dodge become easier to
perform oh whoa
infinite MUP handgun oh my god okay so
there's some good stuff in here
I bet I bet in fact I'm gonna look up
right now resident evil 3 hardcore or
see let's look at like secret ending or
something like that
oh no there's only one ending oh no oh
no that's sad I thought it was gonna be
more oh no is this actually I don't know
but I know oh well I guess I'll get the
infinite mob handgun oh that's so sad
I love the hot dogger
okay so it looks like there's no more
story things to do and it looks like a
lot of these things are what I would
have to do to get the other things which
are just other gameplay items that's sad
man that's really sad that's
disappointing too because the game is
very short so without that replayability
incentive for like a story beat thing
I'm left with just a six hour game and I
know like oh six hours is a long
experience for a movie yeah but for a
game that cost full price I'm probably
still gonna try to do a hardcore one but
yeah that is resident evil 3 I did enjoy
the experience of it I did I had a great
time I'm just left a little sad that the
experience ended so quickly and that the
replayability for more story stuff is
not there there is replayability and
just playing the game again but at the
same time that's loses a bit without
having something to go for the shop is
nice but I wish there was more
it's sad that like after I get the is it
weird weird ending and then now I'm like
oh well I wish it was more it's kind of
leaves a sour taste in the mouth but
still not a bad experience I I still
recommend the gameplay itself is super
fun it was nice to revisit old areas
again and it was nice to see all these
new areas and kind of solve some new
puzzles but yeah just wish there was a
little more what's still fun so thank
you everybody so much for watching and
hope you enjoyed it if you want to see
Resident Evil 2 that I played it's down
there in the description also a short
experience but kind of incentivize me to
go through the hardcore I did a
livestream of that and it was very fun
to do that and then Resident Evil 7
which is another amazing experience and
had a lot of DLC to it like just a
really fun experience throughout I can
only hope that there will be more DLC to
this but then again that's paying for
morrowind
but is what is so thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know you
thought down the comments below check
out the other series I've done in the
description and as always I will see you
[Music]